über whatsapp wurde mir die frage
gestellt ob aliens auf der erde leben
und ehrlich wir können sie nicht
beantworten und es spricht sogar einiges
dafür dass das der fall sein könnte also
dass bereits aliens auf der erde leben
jedenfalls können wir nicht das
gegenteil beweisen also was bringt jetzt
dafür dass wir uns die erde mit
außerirdischen teilen klicks und science
fiction bei uns gibt es jeden tag soll
spannende videos abonniert den kanal
damit ihr auf gar keinen fall etwas
verpasst herzlich willkommen märz 2013
wurde entdeckt ein reptil oid unter den
bodyguards des amerikanischen
präsidenten barack obama es war ja auch
sofort klar das markante kinn der
kahlrasierte kopf die tarnung hat er
versagt ganz klar ein reptil oid wie
alle herrscher der welt bot was ist das
denn
also mal ganz klar so sehen sie nicht
aus es gibt keine reptilien und die
bodyguards des amerikanischen
präsidenten wer immer es auch sein mag
sind es auch nicht tatsächlich gibt es
menschen die sehr speziell aussehen aber
deswegen sind es noch lange keine aliens
obama spielte zwar immer wieder mit dem
verdacht aber es gibt wirklich keinen
hinweis auf außerirdische die sich an
unserem gesellschaftlichen leben steuern
beteiligen würden macht ja auch keinen
wirklichen sinn so chaotisch es im
moment auf unserem planeten zugeht aber
es gibt trotzdem ich sage mal
verdachtsmomente dies nicht ausschließen
und sogar wahrscheinlich machen dass es
aliens auf der erde gibt fangen wir mal
mit unserem gehirn an
das ist nämlich wichtig wenn wir
überlegungen dazu anstellen in jeder
sekunde nehmen wir achtung milliarden
informationen über unsere sinne auf
augen- ohren- tasten riechen schmecken
und sofort das gehirn kann aber nur
einen klitzekleinen bruchteil davon
verarbeiten wirklich nur minimal
das wird dazu dass wir ganz viele
informationen gar nicht verarbeiten wir
klammern sie aus ein ganz wunderbares
beispiel dafür ist eine spiegelung an
einer sich kräuseln wasseroberfläche da
wir wissen dass sich dort immer das
dahinterliegende beziehungsweise darüber
liegende spiegelt überprüfen wir das
erst gar nicht wenn dort also etwas ganz
anderes zu sehen wäre uns würde es nicht
auffallen und genau da setzt der
kosmologe paul day
wie es von der arizona state university
an er vertritt die these dass wir die
außerirdischen gar nicht finden könnten
dabei spricht er von mikroben die
vielleicht sogar in unseren menschlichen
körpern existieren und dort leben
allerdings und darauf baut seine these
auf ganz anders als wir es hier auf der
erde kennen außerirdische mikroben
können anders als die uns bekannten
organismen auf der basis zum beispiel
von arsen säure aufgebaut sein
die dna könnte grundverschieden sein sie
könnten sich vollkommen anders
fortpflanzen
sein ansatz wenn es so wäre wären wir
gar nicht dazu in der lage diese
organismen aufzuspüren alle unsere
messinstrumente unsere wahrnehmung unser
wissen nichts wäre dafür ausgelegt diese
lebewesen zu finden sie könnten direkt
vor unserer nase existieren und wir
würden sie nicht aufspüren vielleicht
existieren sie direkt vor unserer nase
vielleicht sogar direkt in unserer nase
so davies auf dem jahrestreffen der
american association for the advancement
of science aaas vor knapp zehn jahren
und in der zwischenzeit hat sich einiges
getan an einigen stellen in unserem
sonnensystem wurden sogar indizien für
außerirdisches leben gefunden und das
unterstützt eine andere hypothese
nämlich die das leben auf die
unterschiedlichsten arten und weisen
verbreitet wird zum beispiel auch über
asteroiden die insassen unterwegs sind
und zum beispiel spezies wie bärtierchen
die äußerst robust sind von
sternensystem zu sternensystem
transportieren und so leben im all
verbreiten und genau so könnten auch
alien mikroben zu uns gelangt sein und
hier direkt vor unseren augen eben
vielleicht sogar in unser körper nehmen
weil ich finde dass ein mega spannendes
thema wenn er irgendwelche quellen
artikel oder sonstiges dazu findet dann
verlinkt sie in den kommentaren
ich bin extrem gespannt und macht dann
gerne noch mal ein video drüber und noch
mehr videos und auch videopremieren
gibt's auf klicks um in englisch
abonniert den kanal dafür hier klicken
und vergesst die glocke nicht und da
drunter geht es weiter mit what existent
gefordert big bang
ansonsten stay tuned zu tun oder zu jung
bis dann bleibt dran